game of Fabby especially really feels
very good black has just pushed the pawn
shield in front of his king and you know
trying to broke G5 takes F4 Bishop takes
uh F4 and playing for Rook G3 and it
looks like he's going to be the first
winner first first person to win or are
you going to rain on the parade I'm
stand I'm standing here smirking
smirking the engine is uh not because uh
you know you're wrong and I'm very smart
but because I have I have the the the
engine uh saying things to me this is
the least Advantage Fab has had for
about I would say 10 moves it's still
better for white but it is now you you
get the feeling that with with good play
Black probably holds this